yo what's up everybody we are back again
here on Ches comms YouTube channel today
we're going to rock your socks again
with some more basic chest videos for
those just learning how to become chess
players so very beginning chess players
or people still out there on the
internet searching for for a good
instructional videos on the basic rules
and concepts to play the game we've done
other videos in this playlist here you
can see on how to move some of the
pieces on really basic levels what the
basic strategical ideas are you might
associate it with the different pieces
as well as some other things and one of
the most recent ones we did was just the
basic video on how to set up a
chessboard
so again if you're a beginning chess
player who's looking for information
like that to help you learn this this
great game of Kings that it is then you
have come to the right place if you are
an advanced player then you are in the
wrong place and you need to search our
youtube playlists or go become a member
on chess calm and enjoy our videos on
more advanced concepts to the game of
kings so let's go ahead and jump right
in here with the title concept of what
this video is all about which is chess
notation now chess notation has evolved
throughout the years and it has changed
most notably the transition from
descriptive notation was the old old
time more classical way they kept track
and sometimes when you watch movies or
see different chefs Clips it sounds like
more of a cool way to talk about a chess
board so sometimes you'll still hear
descriptive notation used to describe
chess moves or particular positions and
we'll talk about that but the most
common term terms used to describe
notation these days and the the notation
that is generally accepted worldwide and
all chess media outlets and magazines
and and the most PG M which is the term
used for portable game notation which is
when you search for chess games on the
inner and you'll see that term PG n used
which is a file transfer of chess games
that have been played and all those
different sources of chess moves you
will see that algebraic notation is the
most commonly used one and we're going
to talk about that one first before we
get into descriptive essentially you see
there are letters and numbers on
each chessboard and in this case we have
letters lined up here at the bottom on
our board that we're using here you see
letters here starting with the a the a
letter let me have b c d e f g and h
right combine that with the numbers you
see on the left side of the chess board
and you'll see that essentially the
board the chess board and all the 64
squares therein can line up because in
line itself up as a graph when using the
letters and numbers we can give each
square a particular name for example if
I highlight a square what square is that
well you might say for E or E for
depending on whether you say the letter
number first
in general in chess the terms we tend to
say the letter first and then the number
obviously if you said four or six F or
7c someone would quickly be able to look
at the algebraic notation and figure out
what you were talking about but the
correct terminology we use in describing
chess boards is always with the letter
first okay so this is G five here we see
C four okay you get the concept so I
obviously you can back it up and
understand it but there really isn't
much else to talk about in terms of how
to use the algebraic ordinance located
on just about every chess board you see
these days and the algebraic coordinates
are designed to help you quickly know
and write down and notate what move you
just played in a chess tournament for
those of you who are younger players and
would like to play an over the board
tournament someday or even if you're
just a player learning the game and you
do plan on eventually playing in chess
tournaments you will need to know how to
keep chess notation and chess notation
is based on using these algebraic
coordinates so again C to e 5 g seven D
seven F to b5 again you see each time
we're using the letters and the numbers
to describe a particular square and
chess we use the first letter of each
piece to describe the piece now
typically the pawns we don't even use a
P to describe it typically if you move a
pond this move would be notated in
algebraic notation as simply e four as
you can see here this
would be notated as simply d6 but once
again if you wanted to use the letters
if you wanted to use letters like P or
to describe a pawn a capital P or small
P you can do that and of course no one
would confuse it because there are no
other pieces that start with a P but in
general as I said we don't use the first
letter of the pawn we don't use a P to
describe it you can simply say the pawn
itself so the pieces are obviously
you're going to have an r4 rook you're
going to have an end for Knight actually
that one's the one that's not so obvious
as the K the King being the leader of
this army so he's already sort of
reserved the letter K as far as chess
terms go but some players will actually
use KN for Knight those who want to be
more classical or just think they're
really cute because they use more
letters than the rest of us like they're
more intellectually superior but anyway
some people will use the KN for the
night but in chess algebraic notation we
use an R for the rook we use an n for
the night guess what letter we use for
the bishop we use aq for the Queen and
we use the K for the King so right now
we would see the king is on F for Queen
on e4 Bishop on D for rook
sorry knight on C for rook on before so
all those all those things should be
pretty easy for you to understand all
those concepts are pretty simple we use
the letters and numbers to describe
squares we use the first letter of each
piece to describe a piece so if you were
to write algebraic notation this move
here move one of a chess game Knight to
f3 how would you do it that's right just
like that would be good enough and again
you could also use KN but the N is good
enough that would be the way you would
describe Knight to f3 so the only other
things to really review here as far as
learning the basics of algebraic
notation are what to write down for
other moves let's say special moves in
chess the first special move to talk
about might be the special move of
castling castling is something that's
described in one of the videos here on
in this learn chess playlist here on our
chest comm youtube channel and that is
that the move where you can move the
King to squares and the white rook the
that was on its original square having
not moved yet will immediately follow
again this is not a video to describe
the rules of counseling so if you don't
understand that you can go check it out
International Master Depa Prue's
describes it well but castling is
written down in chess as oh - Oh 0-0 Oh
- OH however you want to say it okay and
if you were to castlelong
that would be written Oh - OH - Oh again
if you want to see more examples of
counseling short and long you can check
out David Priuses video on how to
counsel long and short another special
move that you should be aware of how to
notate might be to move on pissant now
again if you understand on pissant then
you probably watch David's video or
you're an experienced chess player if
you don't then go ahead and check out
his video on what on / son is it's
French for in passing okay on Poisson
and and that is described sorry I'm
Poisson is used when a pawn from its
original square tries to move two moves
past your own pawn that has been
extended to the fifth rank and whites
case or the fourth rank and Blatz case
on passant you can capture the pawn as
if it's only moved one and in that case
you would write the school you would not
write h XG five being the square that it
was on you would actually write H takes
G six and write the the rank in which
the pawn ends on not the pawn in which
you captured so here you would be
capturing and writing H takes G six
speaking of takes I realized that I
haven't actually described two symbols
that we use in chess to describe two
very common things and that is to
capture we use the letter X a small
letter X this is how it would look if
you take a good look at it
and when we give check let's say that
here we might make a move like Bishop
takes f7 here we can see an X Bishop
capital B X f7 and you see the symbol we
use for check as a plus sign and chess
we use the plus sign to describe check
the small X to describe a capture and
other than that we're simply using the
algebraic coordinates to describe the
squares that our pieces are moving to
and landing on in that case you can
already see that chess notation should
pretty simple right you use the first
letter of each piece to describe it and
with the exception being the night we
use the algebraic ordinance to describe
what squares our pieces are landing on
so that we can keep track of where
they're going and we use these special
symbols of X and Plus to describe
captures and checks when you combine
that with your knowledge of how to write
down castles you're pretty much ready to
keep notation in a tournament game as
promised I will also quickly describe
for you for those who wonder and here
probably you've heard these terms and
you wonder what that is
descriptive notation is a notation you
can use without the algebraic
coordinates let's see here I'll take
them off so now you see we have no
algebraic coordinates and we can use
this this descriptive notation to
describe the chessboard
if you don't have algebraic coordinates
and you don't have them memorized or if
you just want to be an old-timer and use
this chess terminology what sounds kind
of cool we use descriptive is is is
based on the position of the king and
the queen okay so the movement that was
Knight to f3 would be described as
Knight to King's Bishop three and you
would write it just like this you see
there n capital K capital B and then
three to the third rank up okay a move
like this would be described as pawn to
Queen four you see that we don't need
the numbers to know that if we move four
spaces ahead from the Queen's original
starting square this is the square so
that would be described as capital P to
capital Q four you see how this works
descriptive notation is not used anymore
in professional chess and like I said
other than hearing terms like Knight to
King's Bishop three or pawn captures
King's Bishop three or something like
that you wouldn't really hear it other
than you know chess movies or something
to use it to sound kind of fun it's not
used in modern chess literature if you
have a collector's editions of older
books books published before the 1960s
you'll probably see descriptive notation
used and when I was younger I first
started studying chess with descriptive
notation because the only books that my
grandpa had were descriptive notation
and I learned chess for my grandpa when
I was 10 so I first learned
descriptive notation but quickly
transition into using algebraic notation
as it's obviously much more efficient
and it can be hard to keep track if you
get into a complicated position where
your constant saying pong be king for
pawn to King four if we're using blacks
term blacks perspective both these moves
would be pawn to King four Knight to
King's Bishop three Knight to Queens
Bishop three
Bishop to Queen Knight five that's the
rule Oh PES Bishop to Queens Knight five
right you can see it gets it's a little
bit longer not as efficient and when the
positions get more complex it can be
easy to lose track if you're not really
an expert with descriptive notation so
again use algebraic coordinates as you
as you get better you will have them
memorized you will always know that even
if even if the the number eight doesn't
exist right here you'll know that if
you're black and the Queen is on your
color and you have a right white square
on your right hand and you'll know that
that Square is always a eight and you
won't even need you know the letter A
and the number eight to point that out
to you you'll just know that that as
long as you're black and the queen is on
our color and the like I said the white
score is on your right which means
you've set up the board right then
you'll just know that that Square is a
eight and this square is 'if I've and
this square is b3 so as you get better
you can memorize algebraic notation and
it's useful to do so but you certainly
need to learn how to use algebraic
notation in order to be prepared and
tournament for tournament play and so I
hope that you will take this knowledge
and learn how to keep notation and keep
track of your own games and enjoy the
process so awesome guys we'll see you
around here hope you enjoyed this video
and I'll see you around on chess calm